hey guys what's up so I've been seeing
so many people doing the what I got for
Christmas videos and the laundry's have
been asking what I got for Christmas so
that's what this video is about it's
gonna be a little bit different because
it's showcasing some of the more random
strange things that I got for Christmas
now a lot of you guys may have seen some
of these things if you follow me on
Twitter or on Instagram or even my other
iJustine channel let's just get right
into it let's waste no time here we go
well maybe it's a Justin Bieber
toothbrush thank you mommy
this is pretty awesome it's a Minecraft
torch the best part about it is this
flips down and you can mount it to the
wall like that we actually thought about
getting a bunch of these and lining our
entire stairway with it but it's
probably no it's a great idea what am I
talking about next up is something that
may be a little ironic some of you may
know wise love you may not and IO
because you don't know why it's a portal
gun now the irony kind of sets in when I
actually can't figure out how it works
um so okay well I figured it out if you
want portal inside my mind
I'd suggest you don't a Darth Vader
stocking I know this is real life this
is pretty sweet its iPad cover this
isn't actually that weird but since I'm
a Steelers fan my sister Jenna got me a
custom Justine bumblebee Steelers Jersey
don't worry the weird things are still
coming something that you probably
should never do hold o grenade by the
pin this was a part of a themed Zombie
Survival kicked don't worry there's more
no zombie survival kit is complete well
not a zombies rival guide actually
didn't even open this it shows you how
to hide from the zombies I mean look at
this lure and destroy
this next one who's probably the
strangest gift that I got this holiday
season um this goes along with his mom
beat theme but the problem is I believe
when Ryan ordered this I had to be
careful this is actually real I think he
thought it was plastic it is an actual
real freaking tomahawk and let me tell
you what it's really sharp so I suggest
anyone who thought about trying to break
into my house I think that you should
think again I'd rather take the zombies
down and I have live grenades cops are
pulling up at this this moment next up
is a really cool hoodie kinda funny
story I wore this to Whole Foods the
other day and this woman came at me
she's like oh my god your buddy is like
so yo and she looked again as I held my
arm up and there's zombie bites back
there slashes and the inside in the
brains so when she saw all that she
turned really quickly and walked away
with her little dog in her purse the dog
out of the supermarket now you may have
already seen this one this is a panda
onesie I danced around the Apple store
in Santa Monica in this I also got one
that is a wolf so stay tuned for some
wolf it's another gift but I don't
actually see any hole I do see it I do
see it oh it looks like I've already
have something ready to be printed this
is a label maker
you've never seen a label maker before
and you don't know what one does you
type some stuff and you print it and it
is it's a label this one you probably
can't see it but it says Justine socks
it was labeling everything during the
holiday season now this last thing I'm
not going to get too in-depth with it
because it actually has its own video
coming up very soon so you showed you
have got to be really quiet so don't
wake it up
Oh Barbie kill I actually wore the
sweater because it matched my Furby this
is by far the most annoying thing that
I've ever seen in the entire world no
but I love it
it's kind of like a small child right
anyway I hope you guys had a really
great Christmas stay tuned for the Furby
video because I haven't actually shot it
yet but I promise you it's probably
going to be quite fruit of itting let me
know what you guys got for Christmas
just leave a comment below and if you
have any videos of you guys opening your
Christmas presents just add it as a
video response to this video I'm gonna
prove it and if it has nothing to do
with opening presents don't put it on
this video because I don't want to see
anything but present opening all right
I'm gonna go put this somewhere safe
have a good day